[Music]
jennifer lopez recalls her former flames
as rumors of a new romance heat up I
can't help it the 47 year old actress is
reportedly dating former Yankees star
Alex Rodriguez people reported on
Wednesday that the two have been quote
dating for a few weeks each he reached
out to J Lo's rep who had no comment
during her appearance on watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen JLo didn't
address her rumored budding romance with
a rod but she did open up about her
ex-husband Marc Anthony Oh mark and I
are good the way we are we're great
friends you know we were you know mom
and dad to mex it Emmy and and we work
really well together we're working on
album and it's going amazing we support
each other you know it's it's it's it's
a good it's in a really good place and
we're both happy with it during plead
the fifth and he asked Jennifer about
her previous marriage proposals her
co-star Ray Liotta hilariously
interjected name someone who you turned
down Drake right oh my god I love you
[Music]
you